post-war modernist architecture tends to
be rather looked down on sadly many
notable buildings have even fallen
victim to the wrecking ball time for a
rethink Germany is a vast array of
distinctive modern buildings often
juxtaposed with historical ones many
were built in the post-war era in the
1950s 60s and 70s Architects
deliberately set out to break with
tradition and embrace the new the
results were sometimes praised and often
controversial now these buildings are
being rediscovered renovated and
a new book about the architecture of
post-war modernism is playing its part
one of its authors is under them fun
would lock this what you hear sweeping
statements that these buildings are ugly
but that's just prejudiced four-tire
regular Lucia helps make construction
policy for the city of Berlin filmy his
is not truly to me of course it's part
of my childhood I grew up in a post-war
modernist estate myself so for me it's a
little bit of home he is often struck
himout my engrams team is job is to
preserve historic buildings in her
hometown cologne guarded knock exposure
loans post-war buildings in particular
have a special significance because the
city had been practically destroyed like
most German cities cologne was little
more than a pile of rubble after the
Second World War that included the Opera
House a new one was built in the 1950s a
modern up-to-date building without
historicist references thus far and
anxiety it was intended to signal that
things were looking up everything was in
ruins all around but here we had this
opera house and we had the arts again
tour but the Opera was not well
maintained for materials from the
post-war era and structural damage meant
it required full-scale renovation work
that is set to be completed in 2015 the
office for historical preservation
imposed strict conditions
in Berlin two buildings from this time
are being rediscovered especially around
the zoo in the Western center of the
city the bikini house is almost ready
for its reopening it will look much as
it did in the 1950s with open spaces and
bright colors to make the building
economically viable however a shopping
mall is rent at it with a view of the
famous Berlin Zoo and two fishes by
rashmi gymnastics month it's a typical
example of post-war modernism it has an
air of elegance but of a restrained
elegance it's not opulent it reflects
its time when the men wore narrow
trousers and ties there was a very
specific aesthetic that ran through the
fashion art and architecture at the time
toasty a high-tech talking the
International Congress Center in Western
Berlin is a monumental example of the
aesthetic of the 1970s
the UFO as it's nicknamed is perhaps
surprisingly not listed for protection
the seats it's he is not of course the
ICC is an incredible specimen of
architecture unique in the world it's a
high-tech Colossus on par with the Santo
Pompidou in Paris in Paris contaminated
with asbestosis and no longer running a
profit this UFO is an object with an
unknown future just as uncertain as the
fate of the high-rise known as the house
of travelling on Alexander plants in the
centre of Eastern Berlin though it's in
good condition it's slated for
demolition this master plan released in
1993 foresees new high-rises replacing
the East German modernist buildings so
ye not cite as the master plan at the
time the competition was on and this
master plan was drawn up the prevailing
sentiment in the city was make a clean
slate tabu da awesome that's how the
keynote speeches but that's changed in
the meantime and I think it's a good
thing it's changed in the thought
sentiments and times change but quality
remains quality it only needs to be
acknowledged the house of the teacher on
Alexander plants in the Jason Congress
Hall were both lovingly renovated they
could stand as an example for all of
Germany
knockings what they only come on the
best way to communicate post-war
modernism is to preserve outstanding
examples take care of them and bring out
their best qualities hidden be the
household stiglo I think everything
should be treated equally everything's
of equal value even the periods to come
every period has its own legacy it's got
my knowledge is not in my view it's a
matter of keeping the various layers of
the city legible and integrating them
into the city's history that's who
Indian and not just obliterating them Oh
sue medicine Germany's post-war
modernist architecture dogged by
criticism from the start and by neglect
to the present day but it's time to open
our eyes to this legacy and recognized
it's value in defining the identity of
German cities
you
you